well so there's malevolence that has to
be contended with and then the other
element is that you have to contend with
the tragedy of life and that so in the
in the passion of the christ' did that
in that story Christ of course
encounters Satan in the desert and so
that's and is tempted there and so
that's the encounter with evil
architecting and then the crucifixion
itself is the encounter with the tragedy
of life right it's betrayal and death
voluntarily accepted and so I understood
that that was a symbolic representation
of the logos and that that was the they
what would you say the embodied
manifestation of this heroic path that
mediated between these two extremes that
was really useful like that was a really
useful discovery for me and because
there was implications to it too and and
and profound implications that also
seemed to work out in relationship to
what I was learning about clinical
psychology so for example one of the
things you do if you're a clinical
psychologist is you help people learn to
encounter things that they're afraid of
in a controlled manner and they get less
they don't get less afraid they get
braver
so you actually act out the process of
confrontation with tragedy voluntary
confrontation with tragedy and that's
curative it doesn't matter if you're
exposing them to their past or the
present or things they're worried about
in the future as long as they decide to
do it voluntarily they get stronger and
better so you think well what's the
limit to that well the limit is to
accept the limitations and catastrophes
of your own mortality voluntarily and
and that's the potentially the proper
pathway through life or at least it's
the least bad pathway through life which
is something you know and then I think
the same can be said fairly decisively
for the willingness to grapple with with
malevolence on a personal and individual
level you know on so anyways I started
to lecture about that and and and to lay
out those ideas more and more clearly
over the years as I've been lecturing
and that's what I did for TD Ontario and
I think that that's why the lectures
became popular because you know I'd put
some words to ideas that people already
knew and could revitalize a symbolic
vocabulary that people had become
divorced from and and that there is a
hole in the culture
where those ideas needed to be and so
people found that they were while people
tell me when they come and talk to me
they said well when you're talking it's
like I already know what you're saying
but I don't have the words for it
it's like well that's exactly what our
archetypal story is like is that you all
know the story you just don't know you
know it or you know it a level that you
can't articulate but you still recognize
it when you see it and you still act it
out and you see it in other people but
it's really really really good to have
the words and that's partly why you
should be very careful about what you
say and particularly careful about what
you write